chaque début d'année le plus important
salon consacré à l'innovation
technologique se tient à las vegas le
consumer electronic show rassemble près
de 4000 exposants plus de 150 pays sont
représentés
un rendez vous auquel a participé cette
année la start-up saint-quentinoise est
géré au lift son souhait exporter sa
solution de mobilité novatrice nous hein
on cherche plutôt des premiers clients
des distributeurs parce que si on veut
attaquer par exemple le marché américain
et puis un combat des investisseurs
intéressés au projet qui voudraient
rentrer etc c'est un peu c'est un peu
large nous on est dans une phase où l on
peut se permettre de chercher un peu de
tout si certaines entreprises en sont à
leurs débuts pour se faire une place à
l'international
d'autres ils sont déjà implantés depuis
plusieurs années c'est le cas de presse
comme implantée à montigny le bretonneux
cette pme qui existe depuis plus de 35
ans est spécialisé dans les équipements
et systèmes de gestion de communication
pour les réseaux critiques
ce sont les réseaux qui équipe
la gendarmerie la police les pompiers le
samu les autoroutes certains aéroports
enfin bref toutes les toutes les entités
qui ont une mission critique a assuré
qu'ils ont besoin pour cela de moyens de
communications sécurisées avec une
disponibilité
l'entreprise compte 65 salariés répartis
sur le site principal de montigny le
bretonneux mais aussi sur le site de
recherche et développement à lannion
presse comme affiché en 2010 est un
chiffre d'affaires de 9 millions d'euros
20 % de ce chiffre a été réalisée à
l'étranger
on est présent en suisse et en belgique
depuis depuis très longtemps au mexique
également au canada on est présent
également en côte d'ivoire on est et on
est aussi dans certains pays au
moyen-orient tels que les émirats arabes
unis voilà donc ces cétacés assez variés
on est une petite société donc ça dépend
l'opportune des opportunités qui se
présentent
sachant que pour la plupart d'eux
la plupart des opérations qu'on réalise
à l'étranger on les réalise non pas seul
mais avec des intégrateurs des
partenaires à guyancourt l'entreprise de
jeux de société à ce mode et emploie
plus de 600 personnes à travers le monde
avec 450 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires la société est présente dans
une dizaine de pays européens et
poursuit son développement à
l'international
j'ai démarré le marché n'a qu en 2006
j'étais parti là bas donc aujourd'hui on
a encore beaucoup de travail à faire là
bas mais on a je dirais une forte poster
de dévolution de croissance aux états
unis
on a développé un bureau en chine qui a
un marché émergent sur le jeu un peu
compliqué culturellement et puis ces
femmes des structures de distribution
bien différentes mais on apprend
tranquillement mais sûrement
enfin parmi les grands groupes ayant
leur siège social à saint quentin en
yvelines et qui rayonne à
l'international on retrouve jc decaux
présent dans plus de 80 pays ou encore
zodiac aerospace qui emploie trente cinq
mille personnes sur la planète